that was jumped up went in and got this
assault rifle I think it's an AK-47 or
something and he came out or either
Thompson machine guns one of the two and
he came out and put it in my hand he
said Sonny go kill Mike Stone
so what's the craziest thing you've
heard about Elvis find out on this
episode of LED live
[Music]
lights
welcome to a special LED live I don't
know I think they're all special but
we're glad that you're here and joining
us for the topic of Elvis Presley are
you getting you guys fans of Elvis no
nope
can you sing his songs a lot of Elvis no
I didn't listen to any Elvis and and was
never a major fan of course I know who
he is
um but uh when I saw they were making a
movie about him I was kind of curious
you know like what is this about and and
uh you know what kind of aspects of his
life are they going to highlight so
that's what we're gonna dive in and talk
about
um but any Elvis conspiracies you guys
want to like you know throw out on the
table so I mean I've heard the one that
probably everybody's heard of and that
is Elvis is still alive
in his name
yeah it is Elvis lives if you if you
rearrange the name letters of his name
but it also says evils
[Laughter]
I I don't think he's alive I really
don't I don't think so either yeah after
kind of weighing out some of the
evidence I think he is well gone the
evidence well I I yes the evidence is
really packed up and supposed to be
released on 2027. it was 50 years that
they were going to hold on to it and
then release it so I think if you really
care in the next few years I'm sure
they'll they'll actually bubble what
exactly happened to him it'll be all
over the news yeah so it's a lot of
speculation at this point but
um so I want to talk about the Elvis
movie specifically like baz luhrmann
that directed this um he's done a lot
does anyone know any other pieces that
he's done Romeo and Juliet which one uh
the one with Leonardo DiCaprio oh that
one so he's really known for this
eccentric sort of style of of telling a
story and um there's a lot there was a
lot of people surrounding around his
life that we're going to hear from today
that that talk a little bit about what
what he actually experienc experienced I
think you know in terms of Elvis Presley
did you does anybody been to Graceland
do you even know where it is it's not
that far in Memphis it's in Memphis
right did you know that it's the second
most visited house in the United States
next to the White House the White House
is the first really isn't that an
interesting piece of information and so
um I think this is kind of fascinating
and and the fact that this came out
during the pandemic and everything
um is pretty impressive to begin with
because they went through crazy links to
just make this thing happen but um
um let's dive into it okay have you have
you seen any trailer or anything like
that for this I have a documentary style
or drama no that's a drama it's yeah
it's a straight drama but I want to
point something out like there's this
you know Elvis was very gaudy and he has
it in the beginning of this um trailer
obviously they're making this the very
symbolic of of how Elvis but what do you
guys see on the screen right here well
lots of jewels oh yeah words animals
okay truth freedom and love
what do you think about that what's the
other one it says live a life lived in
fear is a life oh I do think that's kind
of interesting time on the front of a of
a
you know like is that the theology maybe
of of the director and okay sorry I'm
coming like completely like no biased I
know very little of Elvis perfect so
what do you see what's wrong with that
statement well I think it's interesting
because I agree with that that I've
heard a lot of atheists say that in fact
when you say when you say things like
you know I don't live in that fear
anymore I don't believe in that fear
they're talking about religion that's
exactly what I I would have taken it
um and and maybe because I have a
religious bias but I would have taken it
exactly like that like don't we say that
as Christians the peace that passes all
understanding that God gives takes away
fair so absolutely it does yes yeah yeah
yeah so coming through okay too crazy
into it perspective but I see a girl
holding up her skirt and it says freedom
on it I'm gonna bet that like their
freedom is not necessarily freedom from
sin uh you know it's like do what you
want truth I think is interesting that
it's a white elephant or at least that
looks white to me the white elephant in
the room is that is well then everything
there looks white
above the bz what's the bz Iona oh bz is
baz and what's that actually I don't
know how busy is really what truth
beauty Freedom love I don't know I just
thought this was like really a crazy
image I wanted to pause in there to see
if you you guys thought yeah because
everything is intentional right maybe if
you guys in the uh comment section below
you guys want to do some research and
dive into this please let us know what
you find out but I thought this was
interesting that they put this on the
screen all right let's get a little bit
into this so moving on here's a little
piece of the trailer our country itself
is sick
but it's lost its sense of direction
even it's common decency there's a lot
of people saying a lot of things
but in the end you got to listen to
yourself red flag I remember when I saw
it I was like I can't believe that
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things do you know kind of what he was
referencing at this point no yeah I
don't I don't really know what he what I
think he was referencing but I think
that's an interesting statement just
like to focus on okay people are all
saying all kinds of different things
like this but you just need to listen to
yourself
from a Biblical standpoint
what do you think about that hard is
deceitful Above All Things Wicked that's
what I was thinking and our main battle
is with self right I mean that's that's
pretty pretty typical
um Elvis grew up a a Christian
um from what I can tell and a lot of
people think you know he really remained
very true to his Christianity his whole
life we'll see a little bit more of that
and see what you guys think of that but
let's continue on a little bit in that
moment Elvis the man was sacrificed and
Elvis the God was born
you know this is like
so what do you think about him making a
statement that says on that night he saw
the human Elvis die and the God was born
really wild why would someone even say
that
I mean this is how this is Elvis was
treated as the king I mean it's like you
think about the king putting something
ascribing that attribute to him is
interesting so he says the same with
Michael Jackson yeah yeah I mean this is
like this is like you know getting to
this level of Fame I think there are
people that are genuinely worshiping
this person
interesting because there's a family
link there
what do you mean well didn't Elvis's
daughter marry Michael Jackson oh yes
yes yeah that's interesting yeah so you
have the king of rock that was weird
that was really it is weird that didn't
even look like real you know it just
looked totally contrived but last week
oh sorry no I mean this is just like
total side note tangent but I if I
remember right
um
Michael Jackson had owned all the rights
to the Beatles music yeah yeah so it's
like there's a lot of musical wow
control in that family yeah as far as
labels go and so do you do you agree
with the statement that Elvis was
literally treated like a god oh yeah for
sure absolutely okay so how do we treat
that I mean honestly if the Bible does
talk about have no other gods before you
and the world is describing this kind of
stuff to them what do you do with it
yeah we touched on that a little bit in
last week's show where you have these
metaphors these the symbolisms and all
this stuff with these words that we say
nonchalantly to humans that these things
should only be attributed to God and
that's an issue if you believe that
though what he said in that that opening
scene where he's saying that um
you know you got to listen to yourself
well that's essentially what's happening
is you at that point become your own God
your own God you know and so it's it's
not necessarily just Elvis the God was
born that tonight it's everybody else
who ascribed to that same theology just
became a little God as well I'm so glad
that he said that I want you to think
about what he said because as we develop
this thought more I really think that we
all are are are either little attributes
of either God's character or we are
little attributes of the devil's
character I just want you to pay
attention to that because I think that's
really interesting that you you brought
that out this is baz luhrmann baz
learnerman is the director okay it's a
little eccentric
um and uh here he's talking about when
the actor Austin Butler played um this
part how he got into the party worked
really hard I mean this guy just
literally breathes lived slept yeah he I
mean he like locked himself into a room
with as much memorabilia as he could get
his hands on
so when he's making the movie listen to
what baz luhrman says was his kind of
reasoning
um and what they were trying to get at
listen to this
well study study study live live absorb
absorb absorb and then he actually it
becomes Austin Elvis interpretation
because the number one thing was to make
him human
and spiritual
human and spiritual why is there no
backlash when he says it but when we say
it's like what are you talking about
spiritual I want to digest this a little
bit he's basically saying I want to
distill this character down so that I
can show his human side and his
spiritual side huh
I mean anything could be Spirits I mean
new ways new age I can be spiritual you
know what I mean like you can be
spiritual with with whatever belief
system you want yeah so I think it's
interesting that even the directors
recognizing that this is a spiritual
situation and and and this is like the
cook this is like the guy that's putting
the recipe together you're eating this
guy's food when you're watching his
movie right yep so I think this is this
is a a little Telltale of of this
so look at this article here
um even Priscilla Presley explained why
she felt
um Elvis was literally merely God I
think that's interesting that she was
even viewing him as that listen to what
this article says in her book Elvis and
Me Priscilla gets candid about a
relationship with the can't uh Help
Falling in Love singer he taught me
everything she revealed how to dress how
to walk how to apply makeup how to wear
my hair how to behave how to return love
his way over the years he became my
father husband and near nearly God in
modern times who does that remind you of
who does that sound like
a cult leader well yeah I'm talking
about a couple oh I okay well they're
not a couple anymore in modern times
yeah I don't know Connie and Kim oh
that's what she was saying I mean she
didn't go into that much detail but he
was in charge of her image while they
were married very interesting one one
could argue though she was in charge of
Pete's image when they were together oh
yeah you know and that was one of the
reasons I say that he skipped skipped
out because it's like she was trying to
change the way I dress and like all this
kind of stuff like what I ate my
exercise routine and yeah so I don't
know I think people that are in those
high profile positions like that
they probably have a tendency to be very
controlling of their image because it's
their livelihood you know
I think it's really interesting that
she's she's recognizing obviously he was
her provider he was her everything her
whole life was wrapped up in her and
isn't this interesting like you know God
has created this situation where we have
these little mini versions of of God and
the way that we are in our marriage can
actually tell us some information about
God true and if he's sitting there
controlling every knitting pick and
thing that she's doing and this and that
right I mean I I view God as like he has
some pretty hard stances with what you
can and cannot do but there's freedom in
following God I think the devil's the
one that's more or the less the the you
know you've gotta go by his ways or you
know he'll take you out kind of a thing
yeah so I think that's kind of an
interesting article that I found now now
do you think Elvis was aware that he was
like treated like a god do you think he
absolutely believed that he was
successful I mean you can't stare out
and to a crowd of hundreds of people
screaming all over themselves yeah going
nuts yeah you see the videos
yeah I mean people just absolutely lost
their mind right okay so check this book
out this was written
um uh this guy named Larry Geller he was
the hair stylist for Elvis uh I should
have thrown a picture in here but I
didn't so he wrote a book about it and
he wrote about his experience and listen
to what he says about Elvis Elvis
according to Larry Geller believed in
the white Brotherhood of spiritual
Masters including Jesus he felt
connected to them in Elvis's mind his
life was being directed divinely by the
Brotherhood of Masters and illuminated
beings enlightened entities that have
existed since time immemoral and he
truly felt that he was chosen to be here
and now a modern day savior of Christ
the ascended masters are generally you
hear about them kind of in the whole UFO
circles oh okay um you know people that
are like
ascended and and you're trying to Aspire
to them a lot of Eastern philosophy will
also kind of uh uh have this sort of
goal of person to like achieve
um the way I've heard it described as
well is that you have this sort of
um New Age perfect version of yourself
that you're just like trying to get back
to and connect to or whatever they call
this these descended Masters Jesus being
one of them it's the whole new age thing
I mean because the UFO thing is all tied
up in the new age it's all tied up in
eastern religion and um the ascended
masters they like you said include Jesus
in the spectrum of Buddha Krishna and
all these other uh they they feel are
higher above Humanity uh people yeah so
Elvis actually was really into this kind
of stuff right and what's the Bible say
you should have no other gods before me
right so he's getting into all this
Eastern philosophy and and and of course
I'm sure people that are treated like
gods are attracted to a new age type
religion right sure where everyone can
become a God because that's that's
literally how you're treated and you
realize you are actually not the God
right so you're kind of subscribing to
the many gods but the Bible is very
specific to speak against that and Elvis
actually began to dress after the
ascended masters No in fact he was even
designing his outfits and things with
this whole kind of ascended Master kind
of look to it I thought that was kind of
fascinating when I started I'm kind of
diving into a little bit of that so
here's this guy Larry Geller this is the
one that we just heard that talked about
it listened to he was interviewed about
his experience and and this was a huge
long interview so I won't bore you with
a ton of it but there was a little part
that I thought that was very interesting
that um Elvis was big into numerology
listen to this this was very much into
uh what is known today as numerology
um
and Elvis was born January 8th
so according to the main system and
books that he would read
uh his prime number was eight because of
the eighth of January
and um
so he would read a lot of books along
these lines and this was something that
really was of deep interest to him so
what do you guys think about that the
eighth of because of the 8th of January
now what do you think about numerology
what is it oh do you know anything about
it the Bible is totally against that
right that things are happening in the
universe because of numbers and things
like that also once you focus your
attention on you see more often if
you're interested in a Volkswagen you're
going to start seeing more Volkswagens
on the road that you probably didn't see
before so this whole thing with
numerology is also a bit speculative
because if you say oh I want a c44
you're going to start seeing 444 more
often right so he was big into getting
into martial arts he was big he big into
getting Eastern ideas he's reading the
books he's paying attention to a wide
variety now it'll make sense why I'm
telling you this down the road but
um Elvis was not a saint this guy was a
pretty Dirty Birdie if you kind of catch
my drift like he was not a nice nice uh
man even though he said you know people
think he stuck to his Christian values
all the way till death there are a lot
of people that will defend him but so
I'm going to show you a couple of little
Clips right here here he's talking about
um they got in the car late or whatever
and they're going somewhere and they're
talking about the the night before and
he's talking about
um they asked him if he had breakfast
and he um says that he had his face in
it not very nice word and
um they are all laughing about it listen
to this
how was your lunch
there's a mic up there
monologue
oh man you start singing to him right I
mean isn't that interesting what that
shows me is that look he's very
different behind
you know what the public is thinking
that he's like and there he's talking
about being with this girl and that girl
and they're all laughing ah yeah you got
her last night and this and that and
then the guy goes you know you have a
mic in this car and it was like being
recorded and he's like oh you sneaky
then he all of a sudden changed his his
mode and and whatever I think that's
that's kind of a little window into what
kind of man this guy was makes me wonder
how he would I wonder if he tried to
stop that like recording or whatever how
that would have gone up because you'd
think like okay he knows that's being
recorded so you wouldn't want that out
from what I can tell he was being
recorded all the time and when you get
recorded like when I worked in reality
television a lot and people are very
nervous when you first get when you get
first get on camera first day is pretty
rough like you think you're being
watched and all of a sudden like this by
the by the first few weeks into the
ordeal people will do ridiculous things
that you're like you know you're on
camera right you know it's like you just
forget and you just keep going on with
your life and you don't care at this
point
um so Elvis would actually
um fake go into hospitals just to get
away from the media so would you say
then on like reality TV type stuff
do they know and understand that about
people so they know like when they're
going into reality TV show it's like
okay eventually Something's Gonna Come
Out that is good for Show Business oh
yeah and so we just have to warm people
up to the idea and get them used to it
we know it's going to take x amount of
time yeah so we're going to stick with
it yeah so what's crazy is we have they
have story producers that are basically
driving the narrative so they have a
particular narrative that they need to
happen and what they'll do is they'll
keep circling around until that a those
sentences are said that they can make
the narrative go in that direction or
whatever like that a lot of a lot of
reality television shows if you notice
they're driven by interviews well the
interviews are really designed to be
able to steer the conversation wherever
it needs to go and then they actually
pin pin them against each other so if
they want to cause drama hey this person
said this about you what do you think
about that this person they go hey they
personally said this about you what do
you think about that then they stand
back and film the thing and then they
interview about it so they they really
can manipulate where they're going with
it it's very great who's doing that is
that the producers are the ones in there
like a team yeah with the little secrets
back and forth so on some of the shows
that I worked on I mean we had you know
maybe five to ten story producers that's
that's what they're called soy producers
and they literally sit in the room and
watch all the footage and go how can we
make a story out of this wow what can we
do with this how can we steer this but
people who live outside of the public
eye enjoy the Privileges of private life
so we can sit here and look at Elvis and
say Hey you know he's so different in
his private life versus his public life
but that's the case for a lot of people
including us so here on the couches and
I think it's just a reminder it's a
lesson that can be learned without the
consequences of you know public
publicity that um you know we should
take that the Bible seriously when it
says um you know in secret or in public
we should live a certain life have a
certain standard and always bring Glory
To Our God yeah I agree and as a
Christian that's what we should strive
to be is like when no one's watching are
we still a Christian
like you know just just just hearing
people talk like that you know you know
I'm hearing things about a particular
president that said things like that and
and you know you're like oh wow like
that's that's crazy you didn't know that
he was being recorded or filmed and and
you just hear what somebody says like
that and you can only imagine if that
little snip is what got recorded what's
he really like you know when he thinks
nobody's watching I think that's kind of
the case with Elvis too is like I think
like um people are very shocked and
surprised at like what kind of a life he
lived yeah in reality you know we all
are living that experience whether we
know it or not the Bible says that God
will bring every work into judgment
whether it be you know yep uh secret or
not and so
you may not think you're being recorded
but you know God has his records and all
the things that we do even if we think
we're in private or being recorded and
that's going to be brought to light some
days all things are revealed yeah yeah I
love it David said you know where can I
go if I go to the heavens you're there
if I make my bed in in the depths of of
hell you're there you're like like
there's nowhere I can go if I go in the
dark you're there the dark is like the
light to you what can I do and you know
I think it'd be well for us as at least
that believe in God and have a moral
compass that we should keep that in our
form for mind like God is always there
and and you know he's he's I mean that
should be a comforting thought not a
fearful thought that's like you know oh
I'm getting watched on every level
what's comforting is that okay once you
put something on the Internet it doesn't
matter if you delete it it's out there
maybe someone took a screenshot or maybe
it's in like some metadata somewhere but
we have access to a spiritual delete
button God says once you repent and that
means asking for forgiveness and
completely turning away from your sin
you'll remember it no more and so it's
just like deleted from your from your
track record so to speak so that's
something we can take comfort in yep
that's right so
to dive into a little bit more of behind
the scenes this is the bodyguards and
what I think is interesting the
bodyguards all got together and they
they
um made a little sort of documentary or
I don't know what this was back in the
70s but um they got together and they
talked about all these little stories
that
um you know were some very intimate
moments with Elvis and sort of like what
kind of a train wreck this thing
happened
um so listen to kind of one of the
stories that one of them was telling him
it just went from bad to worse there for
a little while you know they just they
happen that's you know and now we'll
start talking to us about this guy
breaking up his home and he all sudden
started losing it and saying things like
it God you don't understand and he's
saying this and that and then that was
set down and he said sonny get down get
down so I was at the foot of bed and I
got down on my knees come here and he
put his hands out
and I took his hands and he said look at
me look at me man and I I started
looking at him he was trying to give me
suggestion by concentrating on you got
to kill him Sonny you got to do it man
you got to do it he's breaking up my
family very low key and I'm fighting no
no no Elvis He said Sonny you can do it
I know you can do it man he's done this
my baby my wife I don't have him anymore
and I said Ellis no no and Red's over it
wasn't Elvis come on Elvis jumped up
went in and got this assault rifle I
think it was AK-47 or something and he
came out or either Thompson machine guns
one of the two and he came out and put
it in my hand he said Sonny go kill Mike
Stone
do it for me go kill him I said no he
had lost her and he knew it so wait
what's the back story on this so who's
Mike Stone I don't know actually who
Mike Stone is but somebody that was
either dating Priscilla or Priscilla was
hanging out with what I think is
interesting is he was extremely jealous
over her yet this man like literally had
a laundry list of women especially how
it goes right yeah you can even imagine
so
um you know it's it's a sad situation
but when you're when you're actively
like engaging like like go and kill this
person that that tells you something
about him and the reason I'm showing
this for you is because if people really
treated this like God
look at where this is going yeah yeah
that's what I that's what I thought so
Mike Stone yeah was a martial artist and
he might have been one of Elvis's
instructors
um I knew I knew he was somehow kind of
like in that Circle of you know either
friend acquaintances or friends or
something like that and so yeah because
I knew that name was familiar but yeah
he was a he was a martial artist and I
think he was either teaching Elvis or
maybe he was teaching Priscilla or
something like that Elvis Elvis was in
karate he was a black belt all right so
that's a little back story on Elvis
we'll get a little bit more into
um the the end of his life here but I
want to I want to kind of transition
into this movie that they created okay
so that's kind of who Elvis really was
you see him in front he's this Mega star
people are worshiping and adoring him
he's this just literally this guy that
moves with the music and doesn't care
what he says and that's I mean they were
literally gonna throw him in jail
because of how he was gyrating on the
stage okay so this this actor that's
playing him has to to embody all of that
together and and figure out how to play
this person so I want you to listen to
this conversation this is part of
channeling him is it the lip curl is it
the hit like what what is it and you
know you got to show me like yeah I'm
listen I wish I could yeah
okay channeling him so she got the
terminology right how many times have we
heard this word pop up in acting
all right let me show you
this is Lisa Marie she tweeted this uh
can you go ahead and read that however
that being said I do want to take a
moment to let you know that I've seen
baz luhrmann's movie Elvis twice now let
me tell you that it is nothing short of
spectacular absolutely Exquisite Austin
Butler channeled and embodied My
Father's Heart and Soul beautifully
okay okay
interesting choice of words that's an
endorsement right there okay this is
quite the endorsement with method acting
do they delve into the both good and bad
you think he can change his lifestyle to
even you know we're gonna get to that
women I'm really glad that you asked
that but we're gonna get to that what
does it say at the top here yeah
channel's the king of rock and roll on
Tonight Show okay so obviously this is
not a one-off little thing that's
telling us what he's actually doing
right okay Austin Butler channeled the
king for the role of his lifetime Yahoo
finance Finance even jumped on this I
thought that was hilarious so this is
accepted language people don't see any
problem with it no problem with this
whatsoever in fact in Google I literally
was like I wonder how many other
channels look at this Austin channel the
thing these are the articles that I read
That's funny because you just typed
Austin Butler Elvis and then it's like
images for Austin Butler channeled Elvis
right right but I just think that's
interesting that people don't have any
problem with this now this is from
Facebook baz luhrman and he had a little
Instagram post and this is actually one
of the
um the screen tests the early screen
test so this was before he had even
gotten the job and everything like this
and
um as they were sitting there listening
to him sing this song I want you to
recognize what the director even says
um he says I feel that Austin is
channeling the vocal qualities of Elvis
oh so he sings in this movie too yeah
yeah
and phenomenally sings it sounds like
Elvis wow I mean if you listen to it
you're like you turn your face away and
you're like is that Elvis like it sounds
like him so do you think the Demonic
world knows it's not even if I replicate
The Voice well I think I think we've
seen that over and over and over and
over again because
um I think it was Roger marneau a guy
who was worshiping evil spirits and came
and became a Christian who said that
these are things that the the demons
greatly enjoy doing they want to mimic
these things in their pastimes this is
something they do for fun they're so
good at it they can take the vocal
identities of people and not only make
it sound like them but they can manifest
like them too so do you think it's
interesting that our parents generation
dealt with this he was alive and well in
our parents generation we know he who he
is kind of right we've kind of semi
heard his music this generation doesn't
really know exactly who he is it's like
these demons are keeping this alive and
think about what's going on if Satan's
final masquerade is to come as the
Christ he's sitting here confusing
people at who the king is
and what is characteristics fascinating
to me that this is coming out at this
point yeah you remember that that
um a video that was circulating in our
office slack about the mass singer you
know the guy was talking about all the
music that he was had created to
influence generation after generation
after generation Max Martin Max yeah Max
Martin
anyway doesn't matter it was a movie
remember
and it was this really old guy and he
was there oh yeah that was the mirrored
singer or whatever did you watch it to
the end I think I watched that whole
clip yeah it was with the guy that
played um Spider-Man yeah yeah and he
was based Andrew Garfield yeah he was
basically the devil and he was saying
like I'm the one that wrote all this
music all these different genres that's
right your soundtrack to your childhood
I wrote it and he's basically talked how
he was influencing like entire
Generations so the other thing I thought
was interesting about some of these
Elvis trailers that they put out was
you know the the definitely used a lot
of Elvis music but at some point there's
this what I would call generational
tie-in they start incorporating all
kinds of different music right there was
like rap and all kinds of stuff uh
interspersed throughout it was kind of a
a different way to catch a wide variety
I think you know that's exactly what
baslerman did here I don't know if
you've watched the trailer but in the
trailer he has hip-hop in the trailer
which I thought was really interesting
he's incorporating the current
generation with the old school message
okay okay so listen to this this is an
interview and listen to
um what he says going back to what you
talked about does he have to embody
everything from Elvis listen to how he
describes this understand that you
reached out to Rami Malek yeah about
this role yeah what advice did he give
you at that time it was it was
um
one the feeling of knowing that
releasing yourself from the unrealistic
expectation that you can make your face
his face and so he really helped me with
this the feeling of
at the the most important thing being
your soul merging with his and then
something new happens that we haven't
seen before if he's merging his soul
that Soul isn't around anymore yeah it's
dead who are you merging your soul with
at this point right listen to this you
remember this story we've talked about
this on this show but for those of you
that are watching and maybe you haven't
heard this illustration before Jesus
told an interesting illustration that
says
um he was he was he was talking about
when a Spirit came into a person and and
he got cast out listen to this Matthew
12 43-45 when the unclean Spirit has
gone out of a man he walks about two or
dry places seeking rest and finds none
and he's safe I will return to my house
where once I came out and when he has
come he finds it empty swept and
garnished then he goes and he taketh
himself seven other unclean spirits more
wicked than himself and they enter in
and dwell there and the last state of
the man is worse off than he was at the
first even so it shall be with this
wicked generation so what does that mean
to you when you hear that I I think it
means
so when you have what what it means to
me is that when you are you can't clean
out yourself you can't this there's a
order operations when you are you want
the bad things in your life to go out
you don't sweep your mind clean first
you instead focus on what is good focus
on the Bible pray to God and he will
come in and clean that stuff out because
if you have an empty house like we say
in the new age you should like not we
but how how they say in the new age I
don't know where I'm going with this but
but they say you know empty your mind
right into your mind well what happens
when something's empty according to the
Bible seven more wicked things come into
your mind so that's that's what I get
out of this yep I'm reminded that we are
vessels there's always a choice that
needs to be made it's for good or for
evil there's no in between there's no
like Middle Ground so if you're not
choosing the right the default is the
bed and that's what you would get filled
see it's been that way since the
beginning though you take the story The
man in the garden and God breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life God's
spirit inhabited Adam from the beginning
he was always filled with the spirit of
God until he sinned and then
you have the separation now he's not
necessarily filled because he's choosing
to not be filled with the spirit of God
and so for us today on this side of sin
it's a constant choice of what are we
going to be filled with are we going to
be filled with God's spirit are we going
to be left empty to be filled with
whatever Spirit comes our way
right so it's it's it's been that way to
be since the beginning and God had
always designed us to be filled
right but with his spirit I think the
bullet point for me out of this verse is
that if you have an empty house and it's
not filled it's going to get feel it's
going to get filled with something that
you don't want it to get filled with and
Jesus is on the outside knocking on our
door right that's what Revelation 3
talks about he's knocking on the heart
of our door who's going to open your
heart to actually invite Jesus in and if
you invite Jesus in you're you're right
Brad He's going to clean out the Clutter
and get rid of the stuff but you've got
to daily invite Jesus Come into my heart
come into my heart but the other Spirits
don't ask they don't exactly invitation
versus Ambush Yeah
Austin Butler was so dedicated to his
role in Elvis that he lost touch of who
he actually is and ended up in the
hospital after filming that's crazy who
does that remind you of okay
Roger they so embody these years well
here's the thing with Heath Ledger I
think that Heath Ledger embodied
something I think he invited something
in and he couldn't get it out I think
that's why Jack Nicholson when he was
told that Heath Ledger had died he said
see I told him I warned him that's what
he said I don't know that
he actually died
[Music]
and so you know the fact that it's like
what you warn him about yeah I think
that these guys are really embodying
these Spirits they're channeling these
Spirits these demonic spirits and yes
you will go crazy and your body reacts
to that
um listen to what this says right here
in quotations underneath the title you
can lose touch with who you actually are
and I definitely had that when I
finished Elvis not knowing who I was
okay who does that find a lot of people
though they lose they lose who they are
like Marilyn Marilyn Monroe
don't know who I am you know
and who else said that it was it was the
the funny guy Jim Carrey Jim Carrey said
that he knows who I don't know who I am
anymore they lose touch with reality
because I think they're inviting all
these entities in right and so it's the
same conclusion whether it's a real
person that lived in the past or a
fictional character
I think it's very interesting to me that
if you invite Jesus in it's like you
have this identity in in in Jesus and
you have this identity in Christ what do
you mean fictional character
The Joker is a fictional character
unless he's based on someone that I
don't know about yeah the Joker is but
Heath Ledger's not no no so right Heath
Ledger invited in something to play the
role of the Joker and then Austin Butler
invited in you know the soul of Elvis so
Elvis was a real person The Joker is a
fictional character yet same conclusion
yes but illness is dead and the Bible
describes that the soul is not living on
so it you know whether you call it Elvis
or whatever they call it a fictitious
character they're both one and the same
they're inviting demons right and that's
that's Ecclesiastes nine five right
correct because uh the dead no not
anything yeah in case someone's
wondering what you're talking about yep
yep okay so let's continue on so let me
play a little more of the trailer okay
so you guys got a back story I've been
building up this case here to say look
Elvis comes out he's this all of a
sudden worshiped as God even his wife
was like you know saying that his
Worship Is God he really has this kind
of dirty lifestyle behind the scenes how
is that gonna play out in his music
listen to this well I'm not gonna put me
in jail why are you saying is God given
so they can't mean nothing wrong with it
okay so he said she said that was his
mother speaking
this voice was given to you by God so
there can be no wrong in what you sing
Dangerous
yeah that's not biblical okay dangerous
we're all on the same page here moving
on quick Bible story um the when the
master gave talents yep and there was a
good way to use it in a bad way ah good
job because they had to get even called
the one that didn't a wicked servant a
wicked servant you're right yes yeah or
lazy servant yep so listen to this
[Music]
living once told me
that things are too dangerous to say
[Music]
wow what kind of a message can you get
across singing that people have no
problem with that message no matter how
easy because of all the the words are
but if you actually came out and you
just said those words in an interview
people would be all up in arms there's a
trend right now people like Millennials
are listening to songs they grew up on
and it's just now clicking the lyrics of
the song and how vulgar it was and
you're like whoa I didn't even remember
that as a child I was singing this and
it was no problem it's the same it's
like once you I don't know what it is
when you're listening to music
the message the lyrics just goes over
your head and you just like I don't know
something else takes over Okay so this
exact thing this exact thing just
happened to me with the song Stand By Me
I've heard this song before yeah which
Stand By Me good song Bad song yeah it
depends which one are you talking about
the one that the one that talks about
when the world's falling and it's
melting down Stand By Me
and it's like wait a minute the world's
falling and burning and you want me to
stand and that you're not sorry for what
you've done and I was like
like imagining like this song I would
have never picked that right I heard a
song the other day in a store of
shopping and I heard it come on the
radio and I heard some some lyric and I
was like well wait a minute like I don't
ever remember hearing that before that's
pretty terrible right right so yeah pay
attention so I think that this is pretty
crazy that he's mentioning this or his
mom mentioned this to him the Reverend
sorry Reverend said this too but before
we go on to that I think what's what's
interesting what you said what we kind
of all Dove off of the conclusion from
all those tick tocks or all those shorts
that that you watch with all those
people saying oh my goodness look at all
this stuff uh that I that has took
terribly songs and I grew up singing
this the conclusion that they come to is
Ike sang it and I didn't I turned out
okay right that's the conclusion I've
heard it from every single one of those
things but have they so the whole reason
I Came Upon this message the whole
reason that it clicked so well when
Scotty 10 years ago did that thing was
because I had said something to a friend
and my friend said absolutely not that's
not biblical why why are you even saying
that and I was like oh actually that was
a quote from a movie I'm glad you really
said that because I actually just
recently spoke to some little kids and
uh there was kindergarten through fourth
grade so you know the range is under
seven eight years old maybe at the top
little kid in the front row had to be
five years old and I'm talking about
like you know the message that's coming
out of the minions and this and that you
know and the little kid raises his hand
and he goes I watched that whole movie
and I'm not a bad person and I was like
wow you're five years old and you're
already having this mentality that like
so what I'm not a bad person but the
point that you're bringing up which I
think is a brilliant point if you really
truly love God why would be Delight in
wickedness why would we Delight in evil
things why would we want our ears to
hear things why even sing a song that
says oh be careful little ears what you
hear if it doesn't matter there's no
reason in being cautious because it will
change you it will it hits you you just
just saying the things over and over
again if you hear them over and over
again then you start saying over and
then it becomes a part of you yeah and
it will change you it might not change
you immediately but that's how seating
works yeah and Jesus wanted us to see
the gospel Satan's doing the same same
thing yep through Hollywood and you know
what's interesting is everybody is
probably in agreeance on this no matter
what side of the fence you're on because
if all of a sudden we started making a
musical song that was slamming lgbtq you
would be on the front news of whatever
and they would be like you know how dare
you see these lyrics why because they're
damaging to people wait a minute if I
say something like that it's damaging to
people but not if somebody puts some
evil lyrics in some song that's that's
not doing anything to you you have to
have the same conclusion on both sides
of that fence that literally what you
listen to has to have an influence on
you or has to have a point on you look
at the pop culture and how upset people
are if you say the wrong words and stuff
but music you get away with it that's
what's crazy all right so listen to this
you want the real
looking for trouble
I came to the right place
look at the trouble
[Music]
looking for trouble to the right place
I'm evil
[Laughter]
oh my goodness the embodiment so this is
kind of some of the lyrics that he's
singing let's just go ahead and read
through some of this
because if you don't think that this is
actually influencing or affecting
anybody I'm just gonna say right here
look at this I'm evil I'm evil as can be
I'm evil as can be don't mess around
don't mess around don't mess around with
me I'm evil I'm evil don't mess around
with me don't mess around with me I'm
evil I tell you don't mess around with
me it's like a warning so it's like mic
drop right here like he's telling you
not to listen to the music
wow this is why we can't take a look at
somebody like this and say
they're
the king they're a Christian they have
all these good morals and you see all
these people because this is really what
the man is like
he's got this like crazy duality in here
okay yeah listen to what his bodyguard
said happened to him in the end of his
life I grew up
with Elvis Presley I grew up and became
a middle-aged man with Elvis Presley and
then all of a sudden
it's over
I knew the drugs had him they were going
to get him and there was no turning back
and I felt sick
and I said I'm you know
I'm going to write a book about my life
story and it you know with Elvis and in
this book um I was going to try one more
time to wake this
idiot up
and he called me and we discussed the
book we had a long conversation his own
tape
and he said
well do what you got to do red
I mean you could just see interview
after interview of all these people that
were surrounding around his life and
they were just like they're so sad like
this guy died in misery and they're sad
but but you know what's crazy is you
they're they're still alive sitting
around talking about it and he's dead
you know why because they were close to
him and they were like uh-uh yeah I'm
not doing that one of the guys that was
in the room in here his job was security
his job was to make sure that everything
was okay and he would wait till Elvis
would pass out and he would try to find
his drugs and dump them out Simply so
that he would live and he would he would
water him down he would do whatever he
could to literally make this guy survive
because he was literally going to kill
himself and so he had this crew of
people around him at all times that were
trying to like you know help him out
what a sad existence if you're security
that's your job I mean you paid to keep
him alive
sad sad existence that's the bait and
switch of the devil right here's the
glamor but behind all of that
you see the darkness so I want to wrap
this whole thought up of basically Elvis
had a lot of inner demons that he was
battling and
um that was clearly apparent in in his
lifestyle and what was coming out and
those that were close to him some of the
things that that
um we know of actually just from the
interviews and stuff from from people
um but Elvis didn't start out like that
Elvis was a Christian he really was you
look at his early life and and he had
some gospel music you know even in the
movie they put that he was going to
Revival and the music when it got into
him it changed him
and so um I want to bring your mind back
to a Bible character that music changed
him as well and these two characters
Saul and David
um it's interesting that when Saul
disregarded what God was asking him to
do that that Soul was was was sad and
salmon was sad but Samuel said something
really interesting listen to this first
Samuel 16 14 but the spirit of the Lord
departed from Saul and an evil spirit
from the Lord troubled him and the very
next verse it says then Samuel took a
horn of oil and anointed him in the
midst of his Brethren this is when David
and passed before Samuel and he was
anointing him and the spirit of the Lord
Came Upon David from that day forward so
Samuel rose up and went to Ramah so what
this tells me is that you can have the
spirit of the Lord for all those people
that say oh he wasn't really saved in
the beginning anyway you know he if he
didn't choose and he went off the deep
end he wasn't saved no the spirit of the
Lord was with Saul he was he was in line
with God in the beginning of his work
and he allowed that demon to come in and
all of a sudden how is the end of Saul's
life what was he bent on
killing David that was his whole passion
was this whole thought process in fact
this whole final movement of anything he
did seemed to center around destroying
somebody else's life
that's not the spirit of God no way and
so you know I think for all of you guys
out there we hope that you got a A
Blessing about this little conversation
that we had here about Elvis but think
about this this is kind of a stark
reminder for you if if you really allow
the music to take hold this music has
the potential to change you I mean
that's clearly being discussed in this
um this video
um even in the acting Styles and things
that they're doing to get in these parts
and try to portray this person merging
their souls together I mean those are
having an effect even on the actors so
how can this not have an effect on us
watching these things I really think
that we should be careful what we watch
what we listen to and you know be
cautious though the the devil is like a
roaring lion seeking whom he will devour
and he just will try to entice us to
worship anything other than our God and
so so we want to make sure that we make
God our King and supreme in our lives
and not get distracted with all these
false views of this so think about these
things do a little bit of research on
your own if you guys got questions
please check out some of our other
videos we've made it made a whole a
bunch of videos on channeling actors
that channel check out some of those
videos you might find those very
interesting and as always thank you so
much for watching our videos like
subscribe share this with people does no
good sitting in uh cyberspace out and
not getting shared so if you really have
a passion to support our ministry we
would welcome your support we love you
guys for even just your positive
comments and and and uplifting things
that you share with us all the time we
thank you guys for that if you guys like
t-shirts and you want to go out and
witness we got a whole old t-shirt
Ministry that we have partnered with
called lightwear and you can find that
at lightwear dot shop and you can see
the link in the description below but we
got a lot of cool cool things it's time
that we start letting Jesus Shine out
from us and ride it all over and uh we
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you guys soon
[Music]
foreign